thank you
thank you
foreign
awesome
foreign
good morning dear colleagues can I
please ask you to take your seats
dear colleagues can I ask you to take
your seats
madame
Madame La Premier Ministry
prime minister
misters
Prime Ministers commissioners
speakers of national parliaments here in
Strasbourg
Paul Henry spark presided over the
opening of the first ever session of the
common assembly of the European coal and
Steel Community it was the starting
point of this institution's plenary
activity
in 70 years the assembly Grew From
strength to strength in 1962 it changed
the name to become the European
Parliament
in 1973 it opened its first own
institutional hemicycle in Luxembourg
where many of our staff members sit
over time parliamentary committees and
political groups activity grew in
Brussels as increased Powers came with
the responsibility of exercising
increased scrutiny over the other
European Union institutions
this institution embodies European
reconciliation
it matters that we are here in Alsace
today as a living symbol of how far we
have come
symbolism is important but this house is
so much more
over the years consecutive treaties have
allowed our house of democracy to
develop into a powerful independent
political Forum with collegeslative and
budgetary powers that impact millions of
European citizens that protects the best
interests of citizens that reflects and
amplifies the voice of 500 million
people
today the European Parliament has become
the only directly elected multilingual
multi-party transnational parliament in
the world
it's 705 directly elected members are
the expression of European public
opinion
with an ongoing illegal war in Ukraine
that destroys kills and undermines the
political will of a people
we are reminded again of the importance
of upholding the democratic values and
voice of citizens and the Democratic
European values that this house stands
for
and that is why it is important that we
Mark the European parliament's 70th
anniversary
it is important that we pause to reflect
on our achievements
the achievement of getting Europeans to
seek and find compromise and to come
together to adopt a common agenda for
the benefit of all
the achievement of making our shared
space a little bit safer a little bit
fairer a little bit more equal
the achievement of creating a union of
Rights of values of solidarity of
equality of Peace of Hope
From the Ashes of War we have found the
wisdom the courage and the humanity to
choose to stand together
to tear down walls and unite people and
Nations together we can continue our
mission to tackle generational
inequalities to fight crippling poverty
to keep us safer and ensure our security
to ensure equality of opportunity to
fight discrimination to stand up for
women to show our lgbtiq community that
this truly is a freedom Zone to create a
framework for prosperity and economic
growth to beat climate change to help
create jobs to ensure dignity to all
I am not here to say that we are perfect
we are not our peace and our process is
sometimes frustrate progress is not
always fast enough or deep enough or
easy enough
we must keep reforming we must keep
pushing for positive change day in and
day out
but I am proud of our achievements of
our way of Europe being a beacon of the
defense of democracy of the way that we
have never been indifferent of how we
have never looked away
friends Europe is the answer to so many
of the questions our people ask of us it
is a way of life and a way of living
it was no coincidence that the EU flag
was raised over her son after so many
months of brutal occupation it is
because it symbolizes hope courage and
belief this is the legacy of our Europe
the legacy of this house the legacy of
the last 70 years
it's
[Music]
along these lines that the European
Parliament comes to vote democratically
every month in Strasbourg and it's in
favor of human rights that European
Parliament is constantly working to
defend their needs and it is for the
needs of our European citizens
that we fight citizens that are impacted
by inflation and by the increase in cost
of living and we will continue to rise
to the challenges together it's here to
watch a video clip prepared for the 70th
anniversary of the European Parliament
thank you
[Applause]
effect
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
tonight president
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
morning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you very much I will now invite
the Prime Minister of Belgium Alexander
the crew to take the floor
[Applause]
Madam president ladies and gentlemen
today's Europe is not necessarily pushed
forward by Visionary leaders like the
ones we know from our history books
human
Spinelli Spark
today Europe's political project is
mainly driven forward by Visionary
citizens by the people of Europe
and that is not abnormal
we do not live anymore in the 1950s
people today are empowered they're more
demanding towards those who are in
positions of leadership
and that all in all is a healthy
evolution
because free and autonomous citizens
together with a free and independent
press are the core of our democracy they
are the guarantee of strong Democratic
accountability
we have felt that public pressure during
the covet crisis
well politicians tended to point out
that from an Institutional point of view
Health Care was a National Competency
and that vaccines Were None of Europe's
business it was the public opinion
it heard the people of Europe who paved
the way for a European response to the
pandemic
as President Van Der lein coined very
candidly this is Europe's moment
and we see now exactly the same
happening in this energy crisis
it is Europeans that see that the energy
markets are international
not National
that energy prices are being used as a
geopolitical weapon that's individual
member states hit the limits of what
they can do on their own
but that Europe should not be impotent
that our sovereignty our ability to act
is not only on the national level but it
is on the European level
and you know that Insight is not new to
European citizens it was already the
case before the energy crisis broke out
in 2019 90 of Europeans thought it was
also Europe's tasks to guarantee the
security of an engine Supply and to keep
the energy prices under control
ladies and gentlemen this house probably
captures best the impatience of our
population
because you know for experience from
experience what it is to fight long and
hard for your rightful place in the
Union
European Parliament has always been the
first Institution
in the formal sense
first in the treaties and first in a
protocol
but for a long time it was not first in
policy making
in the words of Professor David Farrell
for much of his life European Parliament
could have been labeled as a
multilingual
Talking Shop
but today it is one of the most powerful
legislators in the world
today
the Europeans we can be proud of the
road that we have traveled together
miss you
ladies and gentlemen Madam president
having said that
our job of work is far from having been
completed democracy is a task which is
forever incomplete
if we genuinely want to bolster our
democracy we have to make sure that we
also bolster this European Parliament
all the major challenges
[Applause]
it's strange if we didn't get Applause
at that point in this speech but all of
the major challenges regardless if it be
the war in Ukraine migratory flows
Energy prices all of these challenges
are at stake at the international level
so we have to reinforce and bolster our
democracy at that same International
level and at our European level
because the CH the world is changing and
we have to change with it
we often tell people this to our
electors for example it is time for
change
but perhaps we should more often say
these things to ourselves
there are many countries at the Eastern
borders of Europe the Western Balkans
for example but also the Ukraine and
Moldova who see their future in our
family and this new reality has to push
us to change our points of reference it
will force us to take new steps in
European democracy
so that in the years and decades in the
future we'll have more decisive action
and better protect
the European interests throughout the
world and we count on this Parliament to
play that role
we will continue to link up Brussels and
European citizens regardless of the path
we choose to take the European
Parliament inevitably will take a new
Leap Forward in becoming genuinely the
first institution of Europe but I'm
president
thank you
Madam president ladies and gentlemen
I am optimistic about the future
as you said our European democracy is
far from perfect it needs continuous
Improvement
but it is not the delicate plant we
thought it to be over the past couple of
years
our democracy is more resilient than we
sometimes think and this Parliament is
actually the best proof of that
I would like to honor the fundamental
work this Parliament has done in
protecting democracy and the rule of law
in Europe
we cannot leave this fight for
fundamental rights to the courts only we
politicians also have to do our part of
the heavy lifting
and as a member of the European Council
I applaud the Persistence of this
Parliament and the front-runner role
that this Parliament has played in this
domain we need you we need your support
to be a Vigilant Watchdog in that domain
still more Hutch to be done together
with you from the European green deal to
European security energy security and
transition to migration reform we still
have 18 months left before the end of
this mandate the Belgian Council
presidency that we will have in 2024
will stand ready to engage with you to
successfully close the chapter of this
legislator
let me be clear
you are a key partner to us day in day
out your part and parcel of the European
fabric
and you are also part and parcel of the
fabric of my country
and so I would like to say simply thank
you to the parliament
thank you to the Parliament and its
leadership with a special mention of the
late president sasoli
thank you for solidarity it has shown
with the people of Brussels during the
covet crisis and with the Ukrainian
refugees during this crisis
Madam president ladies and gentlemen
let me finish by saying this house
represents the catharsis of a long
history of violence between European
countries
this Parliament represents the victory
of humanity over nationalism it
represents the best in US
the best in US Europeans it is the
parliament of parliaments
and so we look forward to a year of
celebrations with European citizens
which we especially look forward to a
year of continuing work together with
you thank you
thank you thank you very much prime
minister the crow I now invite the prime
minister of Luxembourg Xavier Brazil to
take the floor
president
prime minister Mr Prime Minister
the film that you showed us brings back
some good memories
some memories of when I was younger
people I was lucky enough to work with
such as president sasholi
these are people that to me represent
Europe such as the first woman president
as Simon Vale
I have a speech and institutional speech
I will give you a copy of course with
all the uh thanks that are in that
speech but actually after this film I
want to say something else so of course
a very happy 70th Anniversary
um prime minister the course talks about
bringing the citizens closer to Europe
and I'm sure
um prime minister will say similar
things when it comes to Strasbourg but I
think each capital and each citizen
needs to be brought closer to this
European project we all know
I
would like to uh thank the Secretary
General based in Luxembourg I think we
have very good relations and we will of
course continue uh to do everything we
can for these people who we wouldn't be
able to do our work without
but I'd like to come back to Simon vile
here we are in an assembly it was
created in 1952 so before the Treaty of
Rome seven years earlier
France and Europe France and Germany
sorry that had previously been at War
the war that had ended in 1945 seven
years later there was a decision to
build something together in a
parliamentary assembly to create
something
different rather than destroy each other
to create something together
now why do I think uh Simon Veil is such
an important uh symbol and she was a
survivor of the concentration camps we
had these concentration camps on
European territory this was the result
of an extreme nationalism the darkest
ideology we knew in Europe Nazism
and even now in some European countries
people act as if this nationalism is a
solution to problems
there are people that are Holocaust
deniers still well someone was able to
tell people what she had personally
experienced during the second World War
is
I believe that Chancellor Cole spoke
well when he said this is a project of
peace
peace
our European Union since 1952 since
1957. there has been no conflict between
our countries now of course it's not
always easy but we have not had armed
conflict as we had before
let us not forget that on our own
territory a number of us would not have
had the right to live because they were
trade unionists because they were too
left because they were homosexual
because they were disabled simply
because they were different
today we live in a territory you are
elected by citizens who can freely vote
this European Parliament has such an
important responsibility you are there
to remind us of those values
now I'm certainly not casting aspersions
here
we speak out about what happens in other
parts of the world but also within our
European family it is important to
recall our values our rules
our fundamental guidelines
I could speak of numerous different
rights
there was progress in multi yesterday
when it came to women's rights
but today there are journalists there
are Judges who cannot freely exercise
their professions within the EU
we have stigmatization of sexual
minorities
which is not acceptable so I think it's
hugely important that the parliament
always recalls us of this and that this
conditionality uh is always part of the
decisions that we make
now we believe that peace is something
that we have that these rights are
something that we
have
and I have spoken about the Second World
War I have made this comparison but I'm
very proud to see that there are so many
young people here today you are the
European project I would not have had
the right to live in that period in the
Second World War I uh was liberal I had
Jewish Origins being married to a man
now Belgium that's not related but being
homosexual being liberal being uh get
that would have meant that I would have
been condemned three times over and here
I am today a head of state that is the
European project you might be different
you might have different Origins but
this
richness is not something which limits
us that is where our richness lies in
this diversity we should not allow this
to be destroyed so we are here
celebrating the 70th anniversary of the
European Parliament we need to keep this
diversity which is our strength we
should not be divided whether it's in
Council commission or Parliament I would
like to thank the president of the
European commission and the members of
the European commission who remind us of
the obligations that we have set
ourselves Europe is not just about
receiving it is also giving building
something bigger together so do not
forget that and a very happy anniversary
to Parliament and we will continue to
count on Parliament to remind us of
these values thank you very much
foreign
[Applause]
thank you very much prime minister
of France Elizabeth born you have the
floor
[Applause]
Madam president of the European
Parliament Madam president of the
European Commission
prime ministers
ladies and gentlemen speakers of the
national parliaments ladies and
gentlemen Commissioners honorable
members ladies and gentlemen
for 70 years now France has had the
honor and the pride to host here in
Strasbourg the center of democratic life
of our Union the European Parliament 70
years
an institution that was born in the
aftermath of the war and in the early
hours of a Europe desired to ensure
peace
had a very uh
quick intuition of a need for dialogue
and pitical
construction an institution that has
been marked by its men and women it's
women and its men Robert Schumann
amongst the founding fathers same invoy
the first women president of the
European Parliament David sasoli this
great European who left us in the early
2022 and it is you all of you
the elected representatives of the
European citizens
that bear its voice and its aspirations
70 years this is is therefore an
occasion to go back over our history
a path character characterized by
essential conquests
first the members of the parliament were
appointed by the national Parliament and
then there was a universal suffrage and
direct elections in that were decided in
1976 and the first elections were held
in 1979.
since that very time for 40 years now
you have become not just European
Representatives but representatives of
the European citizens you represent them
directly then there was a conquest of
broader remit
since the very beginning the parliament
had a role of supervision and then
little by little has continued to
increase its powers with every revision
of the treaty with further scrutiny and
all the way up through the Treaty of
Lisbon in 2009 that consecrated
co-decision as ordinary legislative
procedure all of this is a boon of
course to the European Parliament
but also to Europe as a whole because
each time the European Parliament
increases its powers Europe gains in
democracy
now this democracy is a democracy that
we will never fail to defend
at a time when some will assault Ukraine
at a time when authoritarian regimes
would like democracy to be considered
weak we must be proud of our democracy
proud of our values because we shan't
forget that where authoritarian regimes
would
where some would invade Ukraine we
understand very well that by invading
Ukraine Russia is attacking democracy
and human rights the very Foundation of
What We Gather here to defend
and since the very beginning the
European Parliament has defended
equality freedom and solidarity and it
brings a scathing rebuttal to those and
these destructive attempts the heart of
democracy beats here in Strasbourg and
has for 70 years so this is an
anniversary that I think is also an
opportunity for us to look to towards
the future in the immediate future we
will have legislative files to address
that are May that are of great
importance first and foremost fit for 55
as well as for the reform of the shengen
area that is so invaluable to our
citizens as well as conquering our
sovereignty our energy digital
technological and strategic sovereignty
by implementing the Versailles agenda
now this is not an exhaustive list it
does show however that you are at the
very heart of all of the challenges of
our time and the upcoming months will be
very packed indeed
you can count on France we will favor
agreements and work for a stronger
Europe with heightened solidarity and
more sovereignty under the authority of
the president of the Republic you can
count on us to work for that then we
will have the European Parliament
elections
this is a democratic exercise that we
carry out every five years and gives
structure to our Union allow me to
express a wish then that this will be an
opportunity for us to have true debates
where we can make sure that we have a
Europe that is put to the service of our
citizens honorable members I should
finish where I began Strasbourg
Strasbourg is a symbol it wears the
marks of history and at this time where
nationalism is on the rise and tries to
rewrite the past at this time when War
has returned to the European continent
continent
we must continue to recall precisely
where Europe has come from what it has
suffered what we have achieved and what
we will continue to achieve in fact it
is the embodiment of the reconciliation
of the European people our city of
Strasbourg and it shows the strength of
the union and the strength of Peace each
month your Europe's actors all Gather in
Strasbourg and in doing so they pay a
great tribute to our history
and the Very idea idea of Europe of
course there are practical questions and
my government is fully engaged to
finding responses to them but that must
not turn us away from what is essential
at its core Strasbourg is a very idea of
Europe this idea of Europe that has been
built over the course of a time in
different areas of Europe it is a Europe
that has its past but it also has its
common future now this Europe This
Europe that is a symbol of its people
and its territories and it's the best
remedy against any type of Europe that
would be technocratic or disconnected
now through you with all of the European
citizens because of this this
anniversary affects us all it's an
important one I wanted to be here with
you the Vitality of the European
Parliament is the Vitality of Europe
itself hence my desire to be here with
you thank you
madam
thank you very much Madam prime minister
leaders who will have two minutes each
starting with the Epp group Manfred
Weber to take the floor
Madam president of the European
Parliament commission president the
prime ministers
70 years the European Parliament our
Parliament
I have to share with you my personal
experience when I entered the first time
into this institution into this building
I fell immediately in love with this
institution
I experienced the parliament where
everybody counts I was young 31 years
old and I immediately got the trust of
my colleagues to deal with an important
legislation in the Libre file and the
Libre committee the colleagues when you
understand that diversity to have a
colorful perspective about different
ideas to solve problems when you
understand that this diversity is an
advantage then you fell in love with the
European Parliament and that is what I
did when I entered here the first time
it is a very thin line here in this
house
to have on the one hand the party
politically positioned in mind but also
the maturity position when you're
defending the interests of this
institution the Chamber of the European
citizens
it is not the party that is in the
center here not the chancellor not the
Prime Minister not even the commission
president it is the bigger we the bigger
common interest which finally is driving
this institution
70 years ago we hear that our colleagues
gathered here in Strasbourg the first
time
seven years you said it is Lexington
prime minister so you said it seven
years after the brutal second world war
had ended unbelievable bravery what they
showed to us as Europeans
today it's now the right moment to
celebrate this house of democracy a
place where all Europeans are
represented the place where our
political ideas from the coming Goods
bring us together
a place where a multinational Parliament
with broad real legislative power like
no other in the world is present my
group The Epp has always believed that
only a democratic with a strong
parliamentarian democracy a democratic
Europe is a Europe with his future since
its first official meeting of my group
in June 53 my group contributed to
strengthening this house to being
ambitious in the leadership in the
spirit of cooperation with other
political forces and together we were
successful
but now we can go further probably even
much further after this big success in
2014 then the first time this house Sean
Claude Martin Schultz managed that the
commission president was based mainly on
a maturity here in this house
2019 we made other experiences now we
have to prepare 2024.
and the idea behind this that people see
that if they go to vote they participate
they decide about the majorities we come
here together as elected people and then
we decide the program and all of the
candidates for the next five years who
has the power to do it the people in
Europe see the direct link between their
participation elections and then the
outcome on political terms that is what
we want to guarantee and don't get me
wrong as an Epp group leader and as a
deputy president I'm very proud that the
first elected female president of the
European commission is a Epp candidate
and the youngest member a president of
the European Parliament also a female
candidate is an Epp member so we don't
need a quota for this we are very proud
about this
when we speak about the strengthening of
the Democracy I want to underline that
we should not continue legislative
proposals based on article 122 sounds
technical is very democratically
important and you have to strengthen
fill the European Parliament is the full
right of legislative initiatives with
full rights on the budget and we survive
with the full right of Investigations
interest of our citizens so it is still
a way in front of us and I see the
council members now in front of me I
would ask you I really count on you that
council members are not doing these
speeches here in this house but also
when they are at home that we are really
are strong in developing even a stronger
European Parliament and at the time of
democracy is now under attack like it is
the case in Ukraine we have to be the
back the beacon of democracy for Europe
and the world it's a great honor to
serve in this institution all the best
for the upcoming 70 years thank you
thank you very much Mr Weber are now
invite iraja Garcia Perez to take the
floor on behalf of the snd group Iraqi
of the floor
gracias president thank you very much
president ladies and gentlemen
slightly unusual commemoration we could
say when it comes to the colon steel
Union its assembly it wasn't really very
similar to this Parliament it had 78
members from six countries they were
predominantly male delegates from
National parliaments and I say male
delegates because in fact there was only
one woman
and now we have a female president of
the European uh commission I just need
uh to correct uh Manfred Weber it's not
an that she's an Epp candidate she is
our president the president of the
European commission voted for and
supported for uh by this a chamber the
president's represent represent
institutions they represent what we all
defend here
at the time the assembly did not have a
Hemi cycle and they were lent a room by
the Council of Europe and just imagine
now we have this fantastic building when
we see the direct elections in 1979
there was an increase in competences for
the parliament it was a complete
transformation but perhaps the biggest
change is that today we are here
representing 500 million European
citizens from 27 countries
at the time Europe was divided by the
Iron Curtain the first president of the
assembly pulmonary spec said that this
community had not been born to be
against anybody but was born of Freedom
that are more and more people who were
able to benefit from this peace and
prosperity that comes from democracy and
the rule of law and that was the case
although there are still countries that
are missing we have North Macedonia and
Albania that are now beginning their
negotiations and there are others such
as Ukraine Ukraine and Moldova
who will join us it is important to
deepen our democracy it is the
Cornerstone we do not have war between
democracies but things change this is a
living Parliament the conference on the
future of Europe has given us an idea
about the path that we should follow
what our citizens have expected as how
we for example reacting more rapidly to
crises better managing migration more
social policies working more based on
solidarity what this means is a more
political union
and what has not changed is our
objective to have a closer Union and I
would say to parliamentarians we are
Representatives not of our own countries
but of the whole European community at
least that is how I feel when people
from Hungary and Poland ask us not to
abandon them when it comes to the
authoritarian backsliding of their
governments for example some people some
conservatives say that the EU has gone
astray from its Origins but I do not
think that is the case those original
delegates from 1952 understood that
European democracy does not weaken
National democracy it strengthens it in
the same way that European citizenship
strengthens National citizenship so now
it is up to us to maintain that spirit
and adapt it to our times thank you very
much
thank you Racha
I now give the floor to the president of
the renew Europe group Stefan sergina
thank you very much Madam president
Madam prime minister
Mrs Prime Ministers this Parliament
as a European Adventure is a political
miracle
an everyday political miracle in its 24
official languages its three seats in
Strasbourg in Brussels and in Luxembourg
in this chamber
hundreds of different National parties
representing 27 different countries on
various issues the agricultural budget
various other issues
all of this
was
considered as acting before many other
institutions the vaccine for example
Energy prices for example
this Parliament was the first to ask for
a discussion and to adopt measures here
as of 2019
they're more than 18 million more people
who went to cast their ballots
for 20 years now in some countries
we're seeing more people turning out for
European election votes than national
election votes the European Parliament
of course is more
understands more than its media
sometimes that this is where we're
improving daily lives of our citizens
and it's for that very reason that we
need to take that logical step right to
the end looking at the conference on the
future of Europe that we initiated here
in the European Parliament more power
for this Parliament means more
efficiency for Europe
give us the right of initiative
and you will be opening up solutions for
Asylum immigration economic Affairs
issues that we're going to be dealing
with before the end of our term of
office this time around give us the
budgetary power and you'll have more
investments in European sovereignty give
us transnational lists and you'll see a
party that will be able to meet the
challenges of the European Union
more
I'm aware that my group can count on the
support
of the prime minister's present here and
I would like to thank them I'd also like
to ask the other groups to convince
their governments and prime ministers
this European Parliament was has been
elected in 27 member states by universal
suffrage as a co-legislator
this was started off as a dream has
become a reality so
I'm sure we can go even further for
European democracy for our citizens
so that 18 million more electors will be
able to go and vote in 2024. thank you
madam president
thank you for having organized this
event and happy birthday to the European
Parliament may see Stefan thank you
Stefan now give the floor to Philip
lombair for the greens two minutes
on the 14th of July 2009 I came to the
European Parliament for the first time
as a member I will never forget how
proud I was to become one of the 736
represent representatives of the
citizens to safeguard the interest of
those 450 million citizens
and I still feel that same Pride today
as we celebrate the 70th anniversary of
our Parliament
the European Union was the first attempt
to create a transnational democracy now
it may still be imperfect and incomplete
but it is a prototype to be developed in
a world which is increasingly fragmented
and polarized
together we represent just 5.6 percent
of the global population
acting together United in our diversity
is the condition
to strengthen our sovereignty
and when I say sovereignty I mean uh
ability to act and act autonomously and
make decisions to determine our future
as this is our objective the European
Parliament needs to deal with three
challenges as representative of European
citizens the first is our ambition we
need to make sure that our planet
remains habitable for humans we need to
reduce growing social injustices
we need to help people who have been
forcibly displaced from their countries
we need to have international law which
is based on rules rather than violence
we are facing existential challenges
there can be a real challenge to fall
back on an idealized comfort of the past
if the EU wants to really make a future
in the 21st century we need to
ReDiscover our sense of Daring and our
pioneering spirit
the Second Challenge
is that of finding
compromises and agreements we seem to be
surrounded by polarized societies
antagonistic blocks
but our Parliament must show the
strength of dialogue of finding
Solutions this is the only way to find
lasting solutions that will guarantee
that we can all peaceably live together
we need to show that our diversity and
our differences are not difficulties to
be overcome but assets to help build our
future
the third challenge is to preserve our
democracy and our rule of law these are
the foundations on which our Union is
built without them
we would not have peace nor Prosperity
which are essential for the human
dignity of all and for these to be
sustainable
we saw our democracies darken in the
last century as a Prelude to the horrors
of the second World War
we know that this political regime which
Churchill described as the worst except
all of the others is fragile and Mortal
it is both
urgent and opportune for us to see these
assaults to our democracy to the rule of
law within the heart of our Union the
European Parliament must respond to
those attacks on our democracies
whatever member state it might be or
whatever political party they come from
we should never forget that democracies
will die first due to a lack of
confidence
in their institutions and those who run
their institutions
you're right there are still some men
and it was a lot of men at the beginning
it is incumbent all of us to try and
restore that conference our guiding
point should always be the general
interest of all and not just of the few
I believe that we can take on these
challenges and I believe this is the
best possible place to build our common
future thank you very much because we
live
foreign
thank you president
Wonderland Prime Ministers colleagues
70 years have passed since the
establishment of the common assembly of
the
ecsc in 1952.
Europe was a very different place
compared to what it is today
it was the aftermath of two world wars
and we were looking forward to peace and
growth with great hope
at the time the members of that assembly
were
there were only 78 of them and they were
appointed by their National parliaments
and now there are more than 10 times as
many members at some 705 and it's the
European citizens who turn out
to vote for us and to choose us to
represent them we are here to remind
everyone of the values of democracy and
the respect that we must have for our
citizens that we represent here in this
chamber
now the wage that we have as members of
this Parliament should be very much
Guided by the challenges that we face
and of the aspirations that our citizens
have in us and the institutions that we
are part of
democracy in a context of course of
strange nationalism cultures that are
similar but have their own identity
we must respect all of these differences
and not find a way to smooth over all of
the edges we must try to find that
common interest that we have in finding
solutions to our challenges and problems
quick ones and these challenging times
that we are currently experiencing and
go back of course to that Spirit of 1952
that led to the establishment of this
very Institution
at the time it was true that it was the
ecsc that was the full voice of all of
the members states to be able to uh
Express autonomy for the content uh
Continental resources and energy these
are still topical issues today now this
fact I think should remind us all make
us think how is it that we have come to
the point that we are at today
at the outset we made a political
decision to delegate to other
institutions because at the time
industrializing industrializing
um in the area of industrialization we
knew that we were pushed to make these
decisions third countries with issues
related to energy and some of the big
changes that meant that today we have to
come up with the Hasty solutions to a
crisis that will be with us for some
time unfortunately our predecessors have
much to teach us and I believe and I
hope that today will be an opportunity
for us all to go back to the very very
roots of this project and to shift
course to give us the future that we
need now going back to this institutions
I think that we need to follow the
following lines to make sure that we are
we fully realize them we need that to
democracy to make sure that they are
representing those millions of citizens
when we're able to achieve this then I
think we can build State very clearly
that democracy is indeed respected and
represented here in this chamber thank
you
Marco I give the floor now on behalf of
the ECR group to Richard lagutco
Madam president prime prime ministers
two minutes of truth of bitter truth
and the bitter truth is that European
Parliament has done a lot of damage
in Europe
it has been sending a false message it
represents the European Demas
there isn't and there won't be any
European demos
the parliament infected Europe
with Shameless partisanship
and the infection became so contagious
that in spread to other institutions
such as European Commission
the parliament
the parliament has abandoned the basic
function of representing people instead
it has become a machine to implement the
so-called European project
thus alienating millions of Voters
the parliament has become a political
vehicle of the left to impose
[Applause]
to to impose their Monopoly
with
their fears intolerance towards any
dissenting view no matter how many times
you repeat the word
diversity
diversity is becoming an extinct species
in the European Union and particularly
in this chamber
the parliament is a quasi Parliament
because it rejects the essential the
essential principle of parliamentarism
namely accountability
the deputy let me remind you is elected
by the voters and must be accountable to
the voters that elected him not so in
the European Union the idea that say
Spanish German French Etc deputies
accountable to their own National
electorates
can dictate something
to uh shall we say Hungarian Society or
any other Society to which they cannot
be held accountable and which cannot
take them to task is simply preposterous
call it call it what you will
but democracy it is not
to sum up the parliament represents the
demons that does not exist
works for the project that ignores
reality and law
shun's accountability
turns its back on millions of people and
serves the interest of one political
orientation and this is just the tip of
the iceberg having said that ladies and
gentlemen I rest my case
foreign
[Applause]
with your two minutes you have indeed
proven that pluralism and diversity and
democracy actually exists in this house
I I give the floor
I give the floor now to Madame Aubry on
behalf of the left group
thank you very much Madam president
Madam president of the commission
ladies and gentlemen Prime Ministers
today we are celebrating the anniversary
of the creation of the European
Parliament
but we've seen its history today which
reveals the path that still has to be
completed before we've achieved genuine
democracy in the European institutions
and when I hear my colleague Mr Le
goodko obviously there is a long
Road still to pursue I see he's left the
chamber he doesn't want to stay to hear
about what's going on
a symptomatic aspect of this maybe
you're not fully aware ladies and
gentlemen
but these initial speeches by the prime
ministers were initially going to be the
only speeches here and the group leaders
were not going to be taken able to take
in the floor it would have left a debate
in a very restricted fashion so I think
extending the debate to the group
leaders was a good idea now looking at
the history of the European Parliament
and the birth of this European
Parliament
we saw that at the start there was no
universal suffrage at the time it took
27 years before the first MEPS were
actually directly elected by the
citizens themselves 27 years to wait to
achieve what is deemed to be the most
evident political and basic thing how
long are we going to have to wait now
before the MEPS will finally have the
right to initiate legislation how many
decades will it take before our
Parliament has decision-making powers on
all of the legal texts adopted by the
Union
and maybe to act more against
people who are trying to avoid paying
tax tax evasion and we've seen that
Luxembourg is at the heart of this
how many years before the political
deals aren't going to be talked about
and decided on behind closed doors and
heads of state and governments assume
their political decisions how many years
before European citizens initiatives and
referendums be binding and that the
commission be forced to take action
Europe is is the only true democracy
around the world
we know that it's the citizens who
represent democracy
until all that's achieved we're going to
achieved full democracy I've heard you
miss a born Mr Bettle Mr de crew you're
saying that democracy has to be
bolstered I've heard what you've said
but miss born you were talking about
democracy after
what we've seen in France
article 4953
we know that that is not going to happen
in the European Parliament how can you
come here in Strasbourg and claim that
you are a big Democrat when you haven't
been able to do Democratic bidding in
Paris
we see that the conclusion of the
conference on the future of Europe was
very clear on these issues citizens
don't want a Europe that is based on
markets and competition
where the richest win the way
and where European leaders will finally
have to look at
re-drafting the treaties fundamentally
and that's something that we expect and
people out there expect to
[Applause]
on that note
distinguished guests fellow Europeans I
would like to invite you to stand for
the anthem of the European Union
thank you
again
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
moves
[Music]
[Music]
oh Jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
thank you very much dear colleagues the
sitting will be now suspended for a few
minutes and we will resume with the
votes right afterwards